in 2016 the lovely liberal Canadian
government introduced what it called the
medical assistance in dying or made act
and again as in so many other Western
countries it was meant to be only for
people with terminal illness and that's
how it got through it's put through as
if it's incredibly strict
two years ago the Canadian government
expanded the law and two years ago it
was allowed to Encompass people who had
non-terminal conditions
so you can see where this is going
as of March next year this is going to
be expanded again and it will be allowed
to include medically assisted dying for
people whose sole underlying condition
is mental illness
now I suggest that anyone who isn't at
this point ethically concerned
isn't thinking deeply about this